-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Today was so-called
Blackout Wednesday,
which is known as the biggest
bar night of the year,
so, if you're watching me
right now,
you a loser.
[ Laughter ]
Let me also stress that,
if you're watching me right now,
I am fast asleep.
[ Laughter ]
I filmed this show
earlier today.
You're awake.
I'm out cold.
[ Laughter ]
I a loser.
The White House has released
a so-called menu
of accomplishments
that supporters can use
to talk up President Biden
around the Thanksgiving table.
And, that way, your parents
won't even have to ask
if you're still single.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
yesterday launched a campaign
urging Americans to get updated
coronavirus vaccines.
You launched it yesterday?!
[ Laughter ]
We're seeing Grandma tomorrow!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Any other campaigns you want
to start too late?
Maybe urge us to vote
two weeks ago?
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci said yesterday
that his final message
from the White House podium is
for Americans
to get an updated
coronavirus booster
to protect themselves
and their family.
He added, "And do it now
because, after Thanksgiving,
you may not want
to protect them anymore."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, okay.
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
You know what?
Yeah, I might want them to die.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Senator
Raphael Warnock's
campaign yesterday
premiered a new video
that features
Republican challenger
Herschel Walker's
former teacher, which is brave,
because I can't imagine having
to tell people
that you taught Herschel Walker
everything he knows.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Republican Senator Ted Cruz
posted a picture yesterday
with former Democratic
presidential hopeful
Andrew Yang.
Though, if he's hanging out
with Ted Cruz,
I can guarantee he is no longer
Democratic or hopeful.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to a new study,
long COVID can cause
significant brain changes,
but you think
the fake news media
would ever report on that,
you liberal cucks?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sorry.
That was weird.
I don't know.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
posted a photo yesterday
of his vacuum cleaner and said,
"Thanksgiving has arrived."
So, I guess the only mystery is
which of those things
he meant to do.
[ Laughter ]
New York Governor Kathy Hochul
this week signed a bill into law
partially banning the mining
of cryptocurrency,
so, you know what that means.
Hopefully, because I don't.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
35% of Americans believe
that the person with the window
seat on an airplane
should have exact--
excuse me --
exclusive power
over the window shade.
Okay, but whenever they open it,
the person on the aisle
should still get to yell,
"Still just clouds?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Do give an update
to the rest of us."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a museum in Texas
recently broke
a Guinness World Record
by printing the world's
largest book,
that is 7 feet tall
and 11 feet wide.
It also set a record by being
the first book of 2022
that isn't about Trump.
[ Laughter ]
And that, you guys,
[ Cheering and applause ]
was a monologue.